tras meses de protestas el presidente de
Israel se pronunció sobre los planes de
Benjamín netanyahu de reformar el poder
judicial
por el bien de la unidad del pueblo de
Israel les pido que detengan
inmediatamente el proceso legislativo
sus comentarios aumentaron aún más la
presión sobre netanyahu para que
archivara sus controvertidas propuestas
el domingo el Primer Ministro israelí
despidió a su propio ministro de defensa
después de que este rompiera filas con
el gobierno saliendo en televisión y
Llamando a netanyahu a que desechara la
reforma el Primer Ministro netanyahu ha
decidido despedir al ministro de defensa
joaf caland lo ha anunciado hace unos
minutos el Primer Ministro ha destituido
a galantes Pues que este se presentaran
de la opinión pública en un anuncio
especial realizado el sábado en el que
pedía la paralización de la Reforma
judicial el exministro de defensa había
dicho que la creciente fractura social
se ha abierto paso en las fuerzas
armadas y los servicios de seguridad
Israel depende en gran medida de los
reservistas para llenar las filas de sus
fuerzas pero muchos se han negado a
trabajar hasta que se deseche la reforma
el mismo día el cónsul general de Israel
en Nueva York pres entó su dimisión
alegó su oposición a los planes que
calificó de peligrosos
las manifestaciones contra la reforma
judicial llevan 12 semanas y el domingo
se intensificaron
los manifestantes rompieron Las barreras
cercanas a la casa de netanyahu al grito
de vergüenza